la réforme constitutionnelle en russie
très largement adopté les résultats
officiels viennent de tomber à l'instant
selon le décompte final
le oui recueille 77 92 % des suffrages
la participation à tourner autour de 65%
un scrutin étalé sur une semaine pour
éviter une trop forte affluence en
pleine pandémie de kobe de 19
ces votes permettent ainsi au président
en exercice vladimir poutine un
d'effectuer deux mandats supplémentaires
à partir de 2024 réaction de votants à
saint pétersbourg à vladivostok ou
encore sébastopol
j'espère qu'une partie des électeurs à
exprimer sa volonté pour que cela change
j'ai voté pour les changements de
manière lucide j'ai bien lu pleinement
compris des amendements comment ne pas
voter il pas preuve c'est notre
constitution prêcher
nous sommes d'accord avec les
amendements c'est pourquoi je suis venu
avec mon mari je me soucie de l'avenir
de nos enfants et petits enfants afin
qu'ils puissent vivre dans un état
stable je n'aime pas l'idée discutable
de réduire à zéro le nombre de mandats
présidentiels
c'était bien avant donc le doute monte à
la tête évidemment parce que c'est la
seule chose contestable
tous les autres amendements sont
logiques réfléchi il n'y a pas de
questions à se poser